because the White House seemed to have a
hundred different stories about Bin
Laden's death it opened the door to
headlines like this B Laden's secret
autopsy Robert Spencer director of jihad
watch is here to tell us more Mr Spencer
what do you think is it possible there
was a secret autopsy I guess it's
remotely possible Eric but I think it's
very unlikely because what seemed to be
the most important thing to Obama was to
make sure that he didn't offend Muslims
by killing Bin Laden and so he made sure
that he did the Islamic burial the
Islamic funeral within the 24-hour
period after the death required by
Islamic law then of course he made the
major slip up by having the seab barrier
which offended the Islamic scholars and
inflamed everything a new and once again
his attempted appeasement fell flat but
the autopsy would not have fit in with
the Islamic funeral and burial so I
think it's very unlikely that he had it
and um I'm trying to figure out what the
reason for an autopsy I guess to uh
prove it him to get more DNA what would
we need to do that for well yeah that
would be the only reason I mean if the
story that we've heard is true which uh
you know I think we we have no reason to
doubt although there's still been no
evidence for it he was shot and so if he
was shot dead he's shot dead the autopsy
is not going to show a cause of death
but it might prove that it was Osama bin
Laden and and you know the last question
is why why all the the shroud of mystery
around surrounding why not show a Kill
Shot why not if you're going to do the
autopsy tell us about it why not why is
there no transparency it's appeasement
again the main thing he wants to do is
not offend Muslims I mean he comes out
with this Preposterous statement saying
OB Osama Bin Laden is not a Muslim
leader and then he turns around and has
an Islamic funeral for the man which
obviously indicates that he knows full
well that he was a Muslim leader who was
widely revered in the Islamic world and
who taught an orthodox and mainstream
view of jihad violence against
unbelievers and so he's being completely
inconsistent but the one thing that
makes sense of his actions in every case
is that he wants to reach out to the
Islamic world he wants to show that
we're friends that we got nothing
against them it's not going to work it
just shows up his weakness all right
Robert Spencer thank you for joining us
today